when I stood here five years ago our
country was in the grip of an economic
crisis five years on Britain is so much
stronger but the real opportunities lie
ahead everything I've seen over the last
five years and indeed during this
election campaign has proved once again
that this is a country with unrivaled
skills and creativeness a country with
such good humor and such great
compassion and I'm convinced that if we
draw on all of this then we can take
these islands with our proud history and
build an even prouder future together we
can make Great Britain greater still
thank you
let's just see if the Prime Minister
takes any questions that or is it just
going to be the protocol once again with
mrs. gammon Samantha come and the Prime
Minister been very very clear after what
he described as a bruising election
campaign there that he is governing for
one nation and a get reiterating it
mostly a great bit Britain greater still
talked about men Prime Minister of the
United Kingdom I just want to work